and the report again the reports are
just joining us that uh email udoka the
suspended Boston Celtics head coach
according to reports
they said within 48 Hours he would he
would be the new head coach but Sean
marks throwing he said cold water on
that he just said he didn't hire well
first of all Steve Nash is a scapegoat
let's get that out of the way Steve Nash
is a scapegoat for these players acting
like idiots and fools it's really
starting to be a joke
this whole Brooklyn I mean it's past
been a joke and first of all I don't
believe Sean marks I think what happened
with Sean marks is he saw the negative
reaction
I watched television all afternoon
trying to get all the information before
we came on this show people were going
crazy that that guy got a job that
quickly and I think they said you're
joking yes so I think they said yo man
we already doing a lot of stupid stuff
why are we gonna do something stupid
tomorrow so that's what I think happened
because you know when wolves is pretty
damn good he don't normally just go out
there with stuff but I think every
person I saw on television today says yo
man it's a little soon to be giving him
a job who uh email yes so you you
believe that I I I heard this is just
what I heard he said no one's hired he
never said
that is not our guy or he's not in
consideration so there is a difference
between not being hired and not being in
consideration so for me let's see what
these 48 Hours bring brings because yeah
but the negative effect of bringing it
negative I hope coach gets another job
right I hope he gets another job he
deserves another job he did a fantastic
job I don't get into people's personal
life
that being said
this is not what the stuff going on
there it's a bad look to bring him in
you think so yes yes I don't know
because he didn't he because he uh he
hasn't served Independence can he
dependencies with the Boston Celtics
yeah but with the not the Brooklyn but
but he to get him to to do whatever
happened happened but his serving his
Penance with the team that is actually
with the Boston Celtics
but he's not a spend a whole year if
he's gonna get a job tomorrow yeah yeah
but that's not his fault they're
probably gonna fire him anyway well they
are they they probably are going to fire
him but that it's just a bad look and I
I from from a public perception you let
these players run this man off his job
because they were acting like fools the
players this is all on Kevin Durant and
Kyrie Irving and Ben Simmons this Steve
that's just a scapegoat and it's really
unfortunate I don't know if Steve Nash
is red our back or whatever
this thing was never going to work when
he said we don't need a coach
and
you know I was watching these shows
today this team did pretty good in the
playoffs like three four years ago
so nobody was talking about how bad of a
coach Steve Nash was three or four years
ago all of a sudden these guys started
acting like foods and jackasses and now
oh Steve Nash can't coach like I said I
don't know if Steve Nash can coach but I
know three or four years ago he was
winning playoff series